well a top health expert says that
americans will probably be wearing face
masks
for a very long time a senior scholar at
johns hopkins center for health security
saying quote
i think that mask wearing and some
degree of social distancing will be
living with
hopefully living with happily for
several years
dr mark sigel professor of medicine at
nyu lango medical center fox's
contributor
joins us now uh dr siegel several years
i mean the spanish flu in
1918 that pandemic lasted two years
do you see us wearing masks for that
long
actually i don't think we'll be wearing
masks for that long for a number of
reasons eric first of all
we're hoping to get a vaccine which
would help a lot with covet 19 obviously
that would bring us hopefully
up to a level of hurt immunity which
given how contagious this virus is is
over
50 percent of the people here in the
united states being infected or getting
a vaccine
but the real issue here is what's the
value of masks and i think
masks work i think that they're valuable
i wear one myself obviously i wear one
as a physician but i wear it in public
i think it adds something but i think
the key i think he has it reversed
i think it's the physical distancing
that really gives us what we need
because if you're standing and we use
six feet but it's probably farther than
that
six or more feet apart you can't catch
the virus by somebody coughing or
sneezing who doesn't know they have it
the mask protects you from a wearer
who is infected and doesn't know it or
is it coughing
but we don't actually have the studies
to prove how
effective it is so i call the mask the
icing on the physical distance in cake
so i think he has it remember i'm heavy
and by the way if we're wearing a mask
it can't be dirty it can't be dirty
you know it can't be dirty you've got to
change it
i was going to say that you know there's
been some studies it's not just sneezing
or coughing
it's just breathing it's talking it's
speaking
it's singing and that the aerosolization
of
of this can just stay in the air so if
you're a mass that helps protect you
so what do you say doctor do those
people say no i'm not going to wear a
mask you know four states
uh montana south dakota ira wisconsin
they don't
have statewide mandate requirements so
what do you say to those folks
who still push back against wearing a
mask
eric i'm all for a mask again but the
mask protects
the the other people from you if you
happen to have it
it's a barrier and i say to them you
should wear it
government mandates are fine but people
should do it out of a sense of personal
responsibility
social distancing first mask second
the mask is not perfect but it adds
something you could have it and not know
it
you could be pre-symptomatic and you're
about to get it a few days from now and
not know it
everyone should be wearing them right
now and especially in hot spots
all right there's the advice from dr
siegel meanwhile talk about hot spots he
got school coming up
you know what we can do about that uh uh
here's governor
andrew cuomo talking about some of the
concerns
we obviously very much would like to
uh nobody even knows the effect that
this is going to have
on students socialization of young
students etc we want
kids back in school for a number of
reasons
but we're not going to say children
should go back to school
until we know it's safe doctor what's
your advice to parents
well first of all eric i think we have
to start with are we dealing with a hot
spot or not
new york and new york city is doing
really well right now and we've really
batted this down
there's less than 500 new cases in the
whole state of new york
over the last 24 hours so i think new
york absolutely should be looking at
reopening schools
because as we know the death rate among
very young people is extremely low
less than four percent for people under
the age of 44 so the kids
even if they get it get very mild cases
and we can teach our kids
about physical distancing about wearing
masks about hygiene
about washing their hands and using
sanitizer the the
other issue here though is teachers and
here's what i want to say about teachers
and no one has said this before eric as
a as a doctor i'm on the front lines
and i have my patience waiters are on
the front lines of restaurants
i want teachers to be asked teachers
are on the front lines they're going to
want to teach you need to be in person
to really teach i say reopen the schools
yep
all right dr seagal up against the clock
thank you